quand on est dans cette vie
qui pour partir est très officielle en
faut essayer de pas éclater de rire là
où on ne doit pas rire c'est pas si
facile que ça parce qu'il y a quelque
fois des situations extrêmement comiques
[Musique]
il faut observer une certaine un certain
recul mais la nature est là non je suis
plutôt quelqu'un de spontané et de et
certainement en tout cas ou alors si ce
n'est pas le cas j'en suis désolé je ne
sais pas du tout jouer la comédie je
suis très
naturel et malheureusement quelquefois
très utile d'être comédien ça je sais
pas faire
il y a une mobilisation
considérable 5 millions de personnes
20.000 manifestations simultanément
pendant 48 heures je voudrais bien
accueillir une fois
il faut savoir rire
et notamment quand on est dans cette vie
qui pour partir est très officielle en
faut essayer de pas éclater de rire là
où on ne doit pas rire c'est pas si
facile que ça parce qu'il y a quelque
fois des situations extrêmement comiques
et j'ai beaucoup de mal parfois à me
retenir enfin j'essaye très souvent
quand nous sommes en voyage justement au
cours de conversation pendant des repas
elle est très amusante et raconte très
bien les histoires on ne se rend pas
compte de ça mais quand on la connaît
bien elle
aime beaucoup rire beaucoup
alors qu'il a porté
[Musique]
sa collection de câliner
l'humour c'est très important aussi il
faut toujours prendre du recul par
rapport
aux gens évènements il faut essayer un
peu de pas se prendre au sérieux est-ce
que vous savez ce que c'est que le test
de l'écrasement de la face
peut-être pas toujours été assez
disponible pour mon mari dans le sourire
assez cool c'est à dire prendre du recul
par rapport aux événements et être
toujours détendu toujours d'une grande
gaieté parce que un homme comme lui a
besoin de trouver dans sa famille
un contrepoids à cette charge qui est si
lourde et je n'ai probablement pas assez
su masquée ma propre
appréhension des événements c'est à dire
que j'aurais dû il aurait certainement
ça aurait été très bien pour lui d'avoir
une femme
très totalement décontracté explosant de
joie et de gaieté en permanence qui le
qui soit une vraiment un objet de de
grandes détentes j'ai essayé d'être
sereine j'ai essayé j'ai tenté d'être
sereine je suis d'ailleurs assez sereine
[Musique]
dire je veux dire quand on est épousé
Jacques Chirac on pourrait s'intéresser
à tellement de choses
[Musique]
qu'une vie n'y suffit à part
et ma femme a toutes sortes de qualités
que je connais que je reconnais et
elle prend le temps nécessaire pour
faire les choses on arrive avait été
définie par Georges Pompidou très
affectueusement autrefois de bulldozer
moi je suis la femme du bouledozer faut
que je résiste et sa notion du temps
nécessaire est un peu différente de la
mienne autrement dit je suis plutôt
quelqu'un de rapide elle est plutôt
quelqu'un je dirais pas de l'an mais de
réfléchir souvent un petit décalage il
faut
se donner un peu de temps
je ne peux pas vivre continuellement
dans une action je suis pas faite pour
ça avec un rythme on revient toujours à
la tortue mais la tortue est un animal
familier sympathique chaleureux et ce
n'est pas ça n'a rien de désobligeant
d'être comparé à une tortue elle a gagné
par rapport au lièvre
[Musique]